the one thing women can do that men
can't do
is to weaponize their tears
do you know what i mean if a guy cries
his tears aren't weapons but if a woman
cries she knows her tears are weapons
she can have people believe her if she
cries guys don't get afforded that same
thing are you sure about that yes yes so
when a guy cries you know he gets made
into a meme where michael jordan cries
he was made into a meme and will smith
was crying he was made into a meme when
all of these guys are crying they get
made into memes women
why are you offering an excuse
how is that because how do you even know
that how do you know who's making the
memes
because meme culture typically
it's pushed by men
i was speculating
okay we all have to pick women women
women are the majority on social media
much more than men and so it's like it's
like there's always whenever and this is
just something i've noticed in society
whenever we say a problem that men have
it's always followed up by but they do
it to themselves right or
but
men do that too like it's never just
this is a problem well that's why we're
having the show because it's like men's
yeah men's stuff isn't taken seriously
because like i said like i said the the
way women can weaponize their tears is
not the same men can weaponize their
teeth
if a woman ran out right now of here
crying yeah you're more likely to get
garner attention than if a man ran out
of their hair right now crap i heard
this i heard this you know what i'm
saying i heard this and i can't remember
where i went
i disagree so yeah i heard this one at a
time
so i heard this and i can't remember
where i heard it but um but they said
that where the the only time a a uh a
woman is really um
when a woman's tears are genuine it's
when she's by herself if she's if she's
if she's with anybody else normally the
tears aren't genuine
that's why that's what that's what i
heard i had to think about that when i
heard it i heard that too
these are just like they brought you i
remember where where where i heard it
but yeah it makes total sense because
then there's no manipulation they're not
trying to manipulate anybody around
because they're on their own
if you're crying on your own
yeah i'm a woman yeah and i cry with
people okay let me explain it
if you're crying on your own that means
that there's no one else around you're
trying to manipulate with those tears it
means it's genuine because if
potentially there's another person in
the room
that you could be trying to carry some
sort of sympathy
or mercy or favor because you're crying
and women know they can get that don't
play that you can't
because even little kids do it i i'm
conversation because
i have been in situations personally
where i have been crying
and
no one helped me i've called the police
and no one's helped me
i think white women's tears definitely
100 they've got that doubt
as a black female who's big heavy and
tall i don't get that treatment do you
think your tears will be seen over a
black man's teasing
um
by a society yeah yeah
because you still got the female you
still got the woman
i mean
do you know what i think
i actually think it would be equal you
know mean
maybe maybe
that's my experience
okay i'm just i'm just curious i'm just
curious we're just gonna do a quick poll
because there are
four black men in this room and your
experience are your tears seen as equal
to black women go ahead
just pull quick absolutely not now go
ahead
no
no no
but should there be
emotion is emotion yeah right if
someone's hurt someone's hurt doesn't
matter if you're male female black white
whatever if you if you're if you're
showing emotion then that means you're
you're obviously hurt by something by
something
yeah but men don't get to weaponize it
do you want to no no no no i think no
because it's not it's not in our nature
to weaponize our emotions women
women women weaponize their emotions
they can weaponize
they can they do it everywhere can i can
women are women are able to give an
excuse for every single poor behavior
that we do ever oh no
it's even
it's my star sign it's like yeah it's
something crazy it's it's the time of
the month it's my i'm i'm just uh my new
mortgage number
libra
yeah men don't get to do that
sorry direction
yeah it's like yeah women get excuses um
i don't yeah women deaf excuses there's
loads i mean you could be a [ __ ]
because you're you know you're a gemini
sorry for sword there
and on your point of when men don't
weaponize their tears maybe like on a
they can't well hold on maybe on a
sister
on a facial on a face front they don't
but when it comes to
relationships and being toxic and all
those kind of things i've always had the
story it hit me then he cried and then i
went back to because i felt bad because
i didn't do that there's so many so i
think but maybe not in the public face
men don't have that so so that's oh
here's here's for me so many times that
you hurt so for me so like you said so
if i'm in a situation with a man for
example and it was to craft i would
really question that because of what
i've heard that's my experiences of what
i've seen
so every time
every time we heard that story let's say
it was like what five times maybe
plus plus so ten times maybe you've
heard that story so every time you heard
the story they they hit the woman and
then cried mm-hmm or she tries to leave
then they cry so what what people do you
hang around
like that's it like that's yeah
and second second second second thing
second the second thing is that in the
majority of one-sided most abusive
relationships they're abusing each other
and the majority of one-sided abusive
relationships the woman is hitting the
man and he's not retaliating so women
are more abusive than men
why and the reason why are they what it
doesn't
see this excuse what no
excuse why it's genuinely so we can but
i'm saying like what why why does it
matter it's wrong it matters so that we
can okay
if we want to say why i would say it's
because women get bailed out of
everything including abusing men they're
not held to the same like a guy is
afraid to hit a girl a girl's not afraid
to hit a man because look at what
happened amber heard if that happened to
a girl or a man with money status and
power what what does that mean for the
average guy
so like women just aren't held
accountable in society and men are seen
as expendable
which is probably why the suicide rate
amongst many so hide is um if you go to
anywhere in the western world
three-quarters
of the suicides in anywhere is normally
male are those rich men or poor men
but i do i do think one thing i was
thinking about when you said about
um do the society care about what men
have to say and what men have to do and
i started thinking about
is it because men don't care enough that
society doesn't care as well so you know
how women have been screaming and
shouting for riots for this and that
they've been like a non-stop record for
their rights for their for whatever they
want to the point then we've had to
we've we've had to listen to them do you
think the campaigns for you know men
screaming and shouting about we're not
heard we're not going it's enough for
you it's happening it's ridiculed
because you remember when they used to
have um
the men who wanted their fathers who
wanted to see their kids and their
injustice exactly
they'd be kind of written off and
ridiculed they're out there they've been
saying things but
the slant for society and the media just
doesn't give them a voice well even
there was a feminist a couple years ago
that did a documentary on men's rights
and the whole documentary
was aimed like she didn't she didn't
like it going into it she like was like
what what what rights do men need and
she went into it changed her opinion and
had a completely different opinion at
the end she was like you know what men
are actually
seen as lesser in society and are
discriminated against that was her
conclusion and people protested the
movie wow and even men's rights like we
always hear about women's rights we
never hear about men's rights
and even like the red pill space it's
labeled as misogynistic and they hate
when i'm told i hate women every day
because i advocate for men
and even whenever i bring up a men's
issue it's always followed with a butt
and it's it's always a a but either like
men have this problem too like men do it
too or it's a butt like what about us
yeah so remember
men only really started speaking in this
space
for about five years really intriguing
that it's bursting to the scene like the
manosphere and the red pill community of
kind of obviously with kevin samuels it
bursts into the scene but even prior to
that
and men having an opinion
seems to rub people the wrong way but
don't i think but women have had talk
shows for decades they've had magazines
you've had spaces where you can express
yourself i think those men start to do
it i think those opinions were were
there like there were sectors of of of
men and had those opinions but they
weren't
we didn't have youtube where it was easy
access to the mics and the computers and
you can put stuff out there straight
away so look at that there was people
like i remember listening to
uh patrice o'neill like in like 2009
men had to do it through comedy do you
know i mean yeah 2009 i remember this he
was serious and and it was and he was
bringing up some of this some of the
same sort of sort of topics that people
talk about right yeah but you've done it
in a com in comedic so when kevin
samuels didn't do it comedic yeah you
saw it if you're it was another comedy
or it was an informal chat amongst men